blugh activity is on the rise in much of
the country at least seven children have
already died from the virus this season
and the CDC reports high levels of flu
activity in Colorado and Georgia it's
moderate in nine other states including
New York City
flu season generally runs from October
until April and Peaks between December
and February last year the flu claimed
the lives of more than 80,000 Americans
including 185 children that's a record
number our dr. Jon LaPook is here with
what you can do to protect yourself and
your family John good morning good
morning I know you're gonna scold me
later in this segment as I acknowledge
that I have not gotten a flu shot warm
nuts cold we discuss but before we get
to the the information on my personal
situation how effective is the flu
vaccine this year you know it seems like
it's a pretty good match last year was
around 40 percent effective and people
say well that's you know that's not a
hundred percent but it's better than
nothing and even if you do go ahead and
get the flu you can make that flu less
deadly of the hundred and eighty-five
kids who died last year 80 percent of
them did not get a flu that you would
think as a parent you would want to give
your child that better chance on those
no yes the CDC says if you're six months
or older everybody including pregnant
women should get the vaccinated unless
there's some sort of contradiction like
you're allergic to the eggs that the
vaccine is made in so what do you say to
parents who don't believe in the vaccine
who worried that it may cause other
complications well the two big things
that I hear and that are heard
throughout the country are you get the
flu from the flu vaccine okay so that is
just scientifically impossible you
cannot get the flu from the flu vaccine
some people do get a little bit of a
reaction you can get like aches and
pains maybe even a low-grade fever that
night but you take some
anti-inflammatories or some Tylenol and
it goes away but you cannot
scientifically get the flu from the flu
shot and the other thing is well you
know I got the flu anyway and yeah it's
not perfect but again those are the
numbers you're talking about that why
not try to do something to protect you
is it ever too late to get the flu shot
actually the flu season goes all the way
through like April even sometimes it's a
May it takes about two weeks to get for
it to kick in so no it's not too late
go ahead and get it so my big issue with
the flu shot is it's a shot right it is
a puncture of your body to give you
something I don't like needles at all
not even a little bit I'd rather get a
call for ache you know maybe even throw
up okay here they go shot I'm gonna take
that he's rolling in okay yes it can't
hurt him I'll bet you by the way that
their fear of like like Yale Kings out
if you saw me yeah
if I have a fear of shots because it
goes back 50 years I haven't hadn't one
hurt me in like 50 years but it's the
fear of what you're a kid you're running
around they're chasing but let me tell
you this it's not just you your your we
have a growing family your your wire is
it right there is a little one on the
way so that when that little one is born
that little one may not be very well
protected may get a little bit of
protection if your wife was smart enough
to get vaccinated probably she wasn't
all chances okay so but you know it's
not just you you are infected you were
infectious for the flu the day before
you even get symptoms so you know
typhoid mary do you want to be influenza
Tony no I don't want whiskey and
cigarettes so that's you can do with
them you know what I really can't do it
there is a nasal form it's felt not to
be as quite as effective as the shy like
John thank you very much we'll get you
in there for that shot